si vous vous promenez dans les rues au
pecq vous pourrez découvrir l'exposition
les kids dans ce sont treize panneaux de
silhouette de danseuse en plexiglas de
l'artiste alpiq war rénale de zapata ils
sont répartis sur les quais rive gauche
et célia gâte son goût vous êtes avec
nous ce soir pour en parler windsor
bonsoir
plus qu'une simple exposition c'est
aussi un jeu concours oui jusqu'au 6
juin prochain la ville du pecq
récompensera la photo qui mettra le
mieux en valeur les silhouettes des
danseuses en plexiglas plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont déjà participé
vous le voyez sur ces images on a des
petites filles qui prennent la même pose
que des danseuses ou encore des photos
prises à différents moments de la jambe
le but c'est d'amener de l'art dans la
rue le faire sortir la culture des lieux
clos de façon à ce que pendant la
période de confinement notamment puisque
les gens ne pouvaient pas aller au
spectacle ne pouvait pas aller dans les
salles d'expo façon à amener un peu de
un peu de vie culturelle à l'extérieur
des gosses allemand donc comment on peut
participer à ce jeu concours
et bien c'est très simple il suffit de
poster une jusqu'à cinq photos maximum
en participant sur votre compte facebook
ou instagram en taguant les quais danse
ou ville du pecq puis le de s'abonner au
compte facebook de la ville et de
l'artiste et est la salle de spectacles
de qe3
ce propos il était d'impliquer un
maximum de gens y compris les services
techniques de la ville y compris et y
compris le public je voulais pas quelque
chose de passif
pourquoi vous venez du plexiglas célia
c'est un peu étonnant comme matériau oui
et bien en plus ce reynald de zapata
fait normalement de la peinture mais
pour cette exposition il ne voulait pas
utiliser des surfaces classiques comme
la toile ou le bois ce matériau qui est
qui est utilisé depuis un an surtout
pour faire une barrière et le terme de
barrières étant pas très positif je me
suis dit on va le détourner on va offert
une oeuvre d'art ce qui nous manque en
plus cruellement depuis un an et au lieu
de prendre la silhouette intérieur on
avait choisi de découper cette
silhouette comme ce danseur ces artistes
qui nous ont manqué pendant tout ce
temps là en fait on l'enlève et on garde
le cadre qui est autour
les résultats seront communiqués
vendredi 1e juin le gagnant remportera
une des découpes des ballerines en
plexiglas dans un format d'environ 50 cm
fait par l'artiste rénale zapata et bien
merci ces liens agathe son goût d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir